the untold truths of gold rush viewers
tune in season after season to watch the
cast of gold rush live out their
modern-day 49er fantasies but not
everything they do makes it to the
airwaves a little panning reveals that
they take this outdated Old West
profession and lifestyle of there's way
too seriously
bring the canary in a cage because we're
going into the mines to uncover the
untold truths of gold rush killin bears
who cares the gold rush boys don't take
kindly to any varmint crossing their
path not even bears according to the
Associated Press a bear was needlessly
killed during the show's production back
in May 2010 the troubles began when the
bear stuck its nose in some untended
graham crackers and there's no worse
crime in the world than a bear sniffing
at a man's crunchy sweets shortly
thereafter miner Mike Halstead allegedly
tracked the bear down and shot it dead
though it was miles away from the mining
site and probably wasn't actually the
same bear justice had been served kind
of slamming the salmon the miners don't
limit their war on the earth to just
bears they make sure to take out some
kind of wildlife in every way possible
that's why they made sure to drive a 50
ton piece of heavy equipment through a
salmon habitat according to a report
from The Oregonian newspaper according
to the miners state laws allow them to
drive their machinery through rivers and
streams
it's just unfortunate the fish got in
their way the fish were no match for the
rig by that tally they've killed one
large land animal and a water animal
habitat look out Birds your days are
numbered
they basically hate nature
the Gold Rush guys have also taken their
war on nature to the land itself
according to The Oregonian they dug a
trench to divert the course of a stream
most likely to provide water for their
camp this is one clear violation the
Gold Rush is committed as they fail to
erect a screen to keep small fish from
swimming into the ditch
thus they not only increase their fish
body count but they possibly did
irreparable damage to the local
ecosystem as well
nice going team gold slimy producers
with all the acts of aggression against
the earth of course the miners have been
visited by state representatives however
reps weren't there to dole out citations
instead one rep showed the miners how to
use ground water rather than diverting
streams that didn't sit well with the
Discovery Channel's producers according
to regional habitat supervisor Jackie
Timothy the producers actually wanted to
receive a fine the resulting kerfuffle
and media coverage would have provided
the network with some nice discount
publicity for the show too bad for them
things went well parker schnabel
millionaire though he pleads poverty on
the show parker schnabel is actually
filthy rich in 2015 Fox News reported
that Schnabel earned himself a million
dollars during season five a humble guy
he doesn't think people should be too
jealous of him according to Schnabel
he's in more debt than anyone else his
age yet he fails to supply any kind of
numbers sounds like someone is hiding
his gold
Dakota Fred split mustachioed Gold Rush
villain Dakota Fred hurt was a show
fixture from seasons one through four
then he mysteriously up and left the
production and his coworkers dragging
his son with him some think he retreated
to a hermetic life in the mountains
others believe he was raptured what
really happened is according to The
Gazette Review hurt brought up all the
porcupine Creek land where all that
sweet gold digging action takes place
and told the Hoffmans and everyone else
to shove off but really that's not
surprising behavior for a dude named
hurt is it Dakota demanded a raise in
addition to thinking he'd find more
success on his own
Dakota hurt also wanted more money from
Discovery Channel her told The Gazette
Review that quote if the channel wants
him to be an actor they need to give him
the amount of money an actor would get
paid rather than accept Discovery's
offer hurt went on to film his own thing
called all that glitters whether it's a
docu-series or a standalone documentary
isn't known as no release information
for all that glitters has been announced
as of this video's production here's
hoping hurt made the right choice James
harness is fatal addiction miner James
harness was a staple on gold rush for
the first two seasons before he was
fired for missing the one
goals set by the team in his private
life harness lived in constant pain
originally caused by a car accident that
led to his addiction to painkillers
which in turn created harnesses problems
on the show unfortunately his hardships
didn't end once he was let go from the
production harnesses addiction
eventually resulted in the stroke that
killed him in 2014 as reported by TMZ
parts of the show are scripted as with
most reality shows Gold Rush isn't as
real as promotions would have you
believe in an interview he gave to
Oregon Gold fired miner Jimmy Dorsey
claimed that parts of the show are
scripted and some surprising events on
the show are planned in advance
according to Dorsey the Discovery
Channel's producers had scripted a fight
between him and cast mate greg remsburg
which would have resulted in his exit
from the show in the process Dorsey
actually broke his ribs he went on to
say quote they kind of push you towards
making these things happen Todd Hoffman
has his demons in the same interview
Dorsey also airs his feelings about his
former boss Todd Hoffman saying he's a
troubled man Dorsey claims Hoffman
tossed aside friends and family in the
pursuit of fame and fortune even to the
point where he has no problem with
others getting injured Dorsey says that
a particular on-camera dressing-down he
received from Hoffman was not scripted
at all it was pure Hoffman he also went
on to say Hoffman is uneducated in the
ways of mining but ultimately Dorsey
feels sorry for Hoffman at least he
finally found something nice to say
about him thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw